Good morning.
Actually I don't know
what time it is for you,
it's morning for me.
Welcome to the presentation
on slope and y-intercept.
This presentation isn't going
to teach you how to solve for
slope and y-intercept, but
hopefully it will give you
a good intuition of what
slope and y-intercept is.
And we're going to do something
a little bit different
this time as opposed to
what we normally do.
We're not going to use the
chalkboard, we're actually
going to go on to the Khan
academy website and use the
graph of a line exercise to get
a little bit of an intuition
for what slope and
y-intercept is.
So when the application starts
off, it starts with the
equation y equals 1x plus 1.
So that's the same thing
as y equals x plus 1.
But we see that the
slope here is 1.
If you looked at the
introduction to graphing that
I talked about, the slope is
the same thing is the
coefficient on the x term.
And if you see here,
whenever we move over
by 1, we move up by 1.
And I'm going to do another
module on that slope is
actually rise over run.
So it's for every amount
you rise, how much do you
have to run to get that?
And rise just means how much
do you change in y, run means
how much do you change in x.
So here rise over run is just
1, and y-intercept is where
you intercept the y-axis.
Now, as I change the slope and
the y-intercept for this graph,
I think it's going to make a
little bit more sense to you.
Watch what happens when the
slope goes from 1 to 3/2.
So 3/2 is the same
thing is 1 and 1/2.
So notice it got steeper.
And if I increase the slope
more it gets steeper even
more, and y equals 2x.
If I increase any more
5/2 is 2 and 1/2.
So the more I increase
the slope, I think you
see what's happening.
This thing jumps around.
I should fix that.
Let me move it back.
And actually, the goal is to
make the line go through
those two blue points.
That's the goal of I guess
you'd call it the game.
I don't like how this thing
jumps around though.
That was interesting,
let me go back there.
y equals 0x plus 1.
We could have rewritten this as
just y equals 1, because 0x
is the same things as 0.
And notice it's a
completely flat line.
No matter what x is y is 1.
And that makes sense because
this equation would
just be y equals 1.
Now I've been showing you
what happens to the slope.
Now notice we have
a negative slope.
The slope is now
downwards sloping.
It's downward sloping
at a slope of 1/2.
Because let's say the rise in
this situation is negative
1, and the run is 2.
So that's why we get
negative 1 over 2.
And we had just been doing
slope so far and I think you
get the idea that as we
decrease slope, it's going to
push the line further and
further-- it's going to
slope downward even more.
I hate to use a word in its own
definition, but I think you
see that now in the picture.
Now let's put up the
y-intercept a little bit.
And this is even
more interesting.
So y-intercept-- oh boy, how
did that happen, that was
strange --y-intercept--
Notice, negative 1x plus 2, so
the slope is negative 1 but it
intersects the y-axis at 2.
Now if we increase y-intercept
by 1 more it's just going
to push this line up 1.
Let's do that.
See.
Oh, this is actually increasing
it by increments of 1/2.
Let's do another one, I just
want to see what happens
on another graph.
It actually depends on
the actual problem.
OK, this is interesting.
OK, this is the same thing.
We start at the same point.
Let's actually try to figure
out the equation of a line that
goes through these two points.
Well, let's see.
It looks like the y-intercept
if is going to have to
be a little bit lower.
I do not get why
it would do that.
It just brings the line down
as we lower the y-intercept.
And let's see I think the slope
needs to be higher, because
those two points, the line that
goes through them is
definitely steeper.
I apologize for this
thing acting up like.
That looks like about
the right slope.
The slope is like that, and
these two points are connected.
Yeah, I think that looks like
the right slope, but the
y-intercept has to be lower.
Almost there, I think.
There you go!
So the equation of
this line is 7/4x.
So 7/4, that's the same
thing as like 1.75.
So the slope of this line
slopes faster than 1/1 and
you can kind of see that.
I'll show you how to figure out
all this, I just want to give
you an intuitive sense of what
sloping and y-intercept is.
And it intersects the
y-axis at negative 13/4.
That's a little more than 3,
which you can-- negative
3 --which you can
see right there.
Let's see if we can
do another one.
And if you want, we can assign
this module to you and you can
play with it just like
I'm doing right here.
So let's see, the line that
we want to get will go
something like that.
Looks like the current line's
slope is a little too high.
Let me lower the
slope a little bit.
That looks about right.
7/8, so that means for every
8 you move to the right
you're going to move 7 up.
And I'm going to draw that
better in another module.
This module I'm kind of doing
on the fly, so I apologize.
I do every model on the
fly so I guess I really
should apologize.
But you're not paying for this,
so I shouldn't apologize.
Oh, I distracted very easily.
Let's see, let's
move this line up.
And you do that just
by the y-intercept.
You can see shifting the
y-intercept up just shifts
the line straight up.
It doesn't change the
inclination of the line.
The slope changes the
There we go.
The equation of this
line is 7/8x plus 13/4.
Let's see if what I said about
slope is right if we move.
If we run 8, we should rise 7.
So let's see.
Run 8.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
So that gets us right there.
And then we should rise 7.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Well that actually gets
us those exact points.
And we're back on
the line again.
I'm going to draw another thing
like that for you so if you get
confused don't lose heart.
Let's do one more.
OK.
Where's the other dot?
I don't know.
Let me see.
The other dot doesn't exist.
I gotta fix all these
bugs in this thing.
Oh there.
Good.
It showed up.
Excellent.
OK, so look.
We have to make the line go
through these two points.
It looks like the slope
is negative, definitely.
Not that negative, it's like
a fractional negative slope.
And it'll intercept the y-axis
somewhere around here.
The y-intercept is going to
be like 7 and something.
7 and change.
So first of all let's
get this slope down.
Oh boy.
This thing is going to
jump around again.
Notice y equals 0, x plus 1.
If we increase the slope.
This thing is doing all sorts--
I haven't seen this application
in a while, so I must've
written it when I had inferior
programming skills, let me keep
--OK, that slope
might be right.
Let's bring the line up higher.
No, it still seems like my
slope-- see the y-intercept,
I'm raising the line.
Oh good, I got it
exactly right.
And I was right.
The slope is negative, because
you can see it slopes downward.
But it's not sloping
downward that fast.
And that make sense, that
the slope is negative 1/3.
And that makes sense because if
we run 3, 1, 2, 3, we rise
negative 1, we rise negative 1.
Right there.
So that's why the slope
is negative 1/3.
And then the
y-intercept is 22/3.
Well that's 7 and 1/3.
And right there, we intercept
the y-axis 1/3 of the
way between 7 and 8.
Well I think that should at
least give you a little bit of
an intuition on what slope and
y-intercept are and you can
have this module assigned for
you, so you could play
with it yourself.
And I'm going to do some more
models where you actually
calculate slope and y-intercept
and hopefully give you even
though further intuition
on what they are.
So I hope you have fun playing
around with this stuff.
I remember I was very excited
when I first learned
this stuff, because
it's very visual.
So, have fun.